- One of our favorite ways to connect
is with healthy competition.
And if you know me,
you know I love to play and win games.
'Cause it's just what I do.
So every once in a while we
need another host to step in.
I can't play and host.
Luckily we've said our prayers
and know a guy in a rather high position.
He's the biggest star in the galaxy.
You know his work well because,
well, it's all around you.
Voice of God, are you there?
It's me, Kelly.
- [Voice] I am.
Hello Kelly.
Nice to see you again.
(clapping)
- It's so awesome every
time you're on the show,
I love you so much.
So I know you know Jason Derulo.
Obviously, you know all of your children.
- [Voice] Of course I do.
Hello, my son.
You know, I have to tell you,
I just love your work
as a little kitty cat.
- Oh, thanks.
Thank you, God.
Thank you. (laughs)
- All right, well, voice of God,
you have been on the show
a couple of times now in season one.
So what about connection
is important to you?
- [Voice] Well, take it from me,
connecting with other people
in this world is everything.
And I should know because I made it.
- I made it.
(laughter)
All right, well voice of God,
will you help us with a game?
- [Voice] You bet I will, Kelly.
Now this game here is called
"Dear God, what's the connection?"
(celestial music)
Okay, now the rules are,
I will give the names
of two famous people.
Now it's your job to tell
me what connects the two.
So for example,
if I said Tim Allen and Tom Hanks,
you would say--
- "Toy Story" oh, wait.
- "Toy Story"
- [Voice] That's right,
we're not playing yet, Kelly.
But you got it--
- I know, I got,
I get very excited, God, you know this.
- [Voice] Yes, you won the tryout round.
Now, here we go.
(laughter)
Whoever raises their hand first
will be called on to guess.
Now, a correct guess will get a point.
But an incorrect guess
will send you straight
to you know where.
- Dang!
(laughter)
- [Voice] No, I'm just playing.
Now, if you guess wrong,
the other person gets to guess.
Most points wins.
Okay, now how does that sound?
- It sounds great.
- It sounds good.
- [Voice] All right, let's get started.
Here is your first connection.
Will Smith and Tyra banks.
- Oh, I got nothing.
- Me neither.
Wait,
- Will Smith and Tyra Banks.
- [Voice] Okay, Kelly raised her hand.
What you got?
- Was she on "Fresh Prince of Bel Air"?
- [Voice] That is correct--
- What! Yes!
Oh, I love that show.
- I love that show too,
how did I miss that?
- I mean, I didn't remember that.
I just kinda assumed maybe it was that.
I was like, yeah.
- Tyra Banks was in "Fresh Prince."
- I feel like everybody was,
that show was so big.
I mean, God would know.
- [Voice] Apparently you
didn't love it enough,
because you got zero
points and Kelly has one.
(laughter)
Let's tighten that up.
Okay now.
(mumbles)
You got a chance to come back.
Here is your next connection.
- Okay.
- [Voice] Meryl Streep
and Denzel Washington.
Kelly.
- Oh no,
I was gonna say,
Oh, it's the one with her son.
It's not "The Manchurian
Candidate", is it?
- [Voice] It is "The
Manchurian Candidate".
- Yes!
- Oh, man!
- That gets very Shakespeare, y'all.
Seeing her son in that movie.
It's like kinda weird.
I was like, kind of like, "No".
- I ain't see that one.
- Oh, it's good.
- [Voice] It's a
wonderful film and I gotta tell you,
Kelly got two points so far.
Jason--
- Jason, I'm killing you!
- I'm falling behind,
like real behind.
- [Voice] I know you can do it
- Okay.
- [Voice] All right.
- I got the next one.
- [Voice] Here is,
your next connection is,
Amelia Clark and Peter Dinklage.
- I got it.
- [Voice] Here you go, Jason.
- "Game of Thrones."
- [Voice] "Game of Thrones" it is.
- Woo, coming back.
- [Voice] Jason,
you now on the board,
you got one point, Kelly got two.
She's in the lead.
Here is our next connection.
Everybody get ready,
hang on tight,
because your next
connection is Taylor Swift
and Dame Judi Dench.
- Oh, got it.
- [Voice] Oh, Jason,
did you say it?
- Yup, "Cats".
- [Voice] That's it, I just
wanted to hear you say it again.
- Oh that's unfair.
Oh my gosh, that's not fair.
I totally, how did not remember that?
Okay, go ahead.
- Oh, we tied up!
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Voice] Now, we got
ourselves a tie game here.
Here is your next connection.
- Okay.
- [Voice] Tupac Shakur
and Janet Jackson.
- Oh, got it.
- [Voice] Jason Derulo.
- "Poetic Justice" is
what it's called, I think?
- [Voice] "Poetic Justice" it is.
- Yes!
- Oh my God, I haven't
seen that in forever.
I couldn't even remember that.
- [Voice] It is.
And this lead is poetic.
Jason with three points,
and Kelly has two.
Come on girl, I know you can do better--
- Ooh, I knew I was gonna come back now.
- [Voice] Here it is,
your next connection,
Joe Exotic and Carol Baskins.
- [Jason] Oh, I got it.
- [Voice] Oh, Ooh, I think
Kelly raised their hand.
I think I saw it.
- "Tiger King".
- [Voice] I think it's, yes, you said it.
- [Voice] That's it,
"Tiger King".
- Yes, crazy show.
(laughter)
- [Voice] Okay.
Now listen, y'all.
We have a time game here
and we are about to give
you your final connection.
So this is for the game.
- Okay.
- [Voice] Don't let me down.
Here you go.
Your final connection is Sasha
Baron Cohen and Will Ferrell.
Oh, Kelly.
- "Talladega Nights"!
- "Talladega Nights", Kelly is
- I didn't know that one.
I didn't know that,
and you deserve it 'cause I didn't even.
- Did you not see "Talladega Nights"?
- Nah.
Should I watch it?
- Oh my God, it is so funny.
- Oh, I gotta go check it out.
- That's kinda I feel not fair
'cause I saw that and you didn't,
but I didn't see I haven't seen
"Poetic Justice" in forever.
- Yeah.
- That was a good one.
- I caught up, though.
- I gotta be honest with you.
I'm sweating in my space suit, man.
I totally thought I was losing that.
Well, thank you so much voice of God.
- [Voice] Thank you, as
always it's a pleasure.
And Jason, pleasure to talk to you my son.
- Likewise.
- Keep everyone
safe out there, all right?
And it's always good to see you again.
- [Voice] Yeah, I gotta go
take care of some things.
I'm very busy, as you can imagine.
Now, take care.
(laughter)
- I guess you are.
Thank you so much, Jason.
I always love having you on and good luck.
Like, I totally understand about
just getting away from something
and having a fresh start,
like especially in your career.
And that's really cool and
I'm really excited for you.
Everybody, don't forget to
check out Jason's single
"Take you dancing".
It's awesome.